hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay we are in
the halls of the Dead the frozen depths
of sorrow and demise sanctified
underground of death and dismemberment
yeah I think that's good nice high five
to me coming up with that oh I'm so
afraid why should creamy guys gonna come
out of that what was that huh
Buju ha ha how's this happening
huh wha y'all want some of me can't
handle none of me now many can murder
another one escaped did
wait isn't my ghost going through the
same thing because this wasn't is I
going crazy
oh ha ha ha ha no don't you see buddy
close not close all about you the nerd
there they're getting that that was that
was effective that was quite quite
effective he's just he just went
everywhere all of a sudden he didn't
even drop a goodie how dare he
or her the goodie gut like exploded out
of the map I'm out of mana medkit oh no
oh no oh no I need a story I've never
had to fly on that kid in my life oh
yeah I reload I need to be more
proactive if I'm gonna be using this
grenade launcher detonator which I like
one there one there one there and one
there now nothing can get me oh oh
boo dude I like that yeah I guess I
could leave those there go my merry way
now ah Oh got you ha oh is that another
one
ha ha ha ha right now no no what the
hell how'd that happen how'd you get
past my ultimate defense got another one
bull honky I'd too much longer did I get
all of them I'm dying man something hit
me from behind
I don't know what I don't know but I
need a med kid like real bad
don't touch up punk got ya can't hide
from me too smart too handsome too great
for the legs are you oh you oh it hurts
so bad oh I can barely walk oh I can't
feel my arms and legs
kudos you watched enough of my videos
that you know I'm what I'm referencing
well it's looks fancy gonna go just
jiggle they're just dancing
that's what I was doing at the bar last
night I love to dance sometimes you just
want to go out and just dance Dana what
do I about me Dana
[ __ ] love your expletives Isaac aren't
you
[ __ ] come on with that help
down here ain't gonna be proactive ah
damn it
yes I need to go up I need to get down
yeah well these days I'll make a video
and show you guys my moves
what am I doing here Oh stasis obviously
this asus everywhere
oh is this power node and a doodad
forget more doodad juice and rust my
hand up into this anybody Oh yep super
happy up a little bit best Oh
oh yeah
attention
Oh
oh okay stasis it okay I got it
watch this so great oh yeah got it
but that wasn't it oh I got to get all
of them okay down
- as oh yeah so the best Oh 10 billion
bonus points units great oh I had a
health care about time was there not one
more
but L know this
no one oh I see oh there it is in front
of my face
got it anna-news
oh yeah take that gravity huh get out of
here
ooh I like that little nice touches okay
that's not
how do I get out of here the for good
thing is gone
oh okay how does all right yeah there we
go ha ha
safety this yeah move through oh let me
through
I need you go oh let me through here we
go ah come away come away biznitch there
we go
we gooo schematic media med pack justice
stuff I needed this is so cool look at
me go I'm like a majestic butterfly
riding a unicorn across a rainbow wasn't
that nice nice nice
that's all right back okay point point
point point cuz yeah look uh stupid I
remind I'm such an idiot
hahaha I'm not Isaac look at Isaac it's
such a dork
look at him rock well no don't go in the
air ok but there's a dude out here to
restore gravity how did that why
couldn't I just push the button to turn
gravity off
hello baby dammit I think they're
joining everything with a mobile device
Oh give me a frequency on my channel who
else is there
should I be jealous the compound no
change plants
if they knew where we were they would
have killed us by now okay okay that's
all I've been doing
maybe not hurrying because I've been
trying to be cautious climate control
led CTO three 8005 MTO seven okay
whatever that means here star yes did I
check behind me so I'm gonna get me
there's a lot of schematics okay anyway
j'son's get out of here God don't need
you got plenty of line racks I should
probably use them I don't have the pulse
rifle at the moment sauce with that out
I'll give the flame thing one more try
but if not I'm just gonna replace it
okay I definitely need more plasma
energy that's a given
what's this pulse rifle receives a five
percent bonus to damage I want a 5%
bonus to the pulse rifle but no alas I
shall not I'm holding off on that if I
don't find anything else interesting
besides it I'll get it
they're not yet I need I need plasma
energy I need med kits just do and med
kits I thought that was way too many med
kits what am i doing why did why in the
world did I buy that many med kits why
they're 5,000 - Pete I just wasted like
all my mother all right well I mean it's
not like it's a big deal
I've one syringe I put two in storage
cuz I'm gonna pick some up obviously on
the way whatever it's not like I won't
need them later on I need one right now
boo do all this stuff who wants them ah
ah the lights just had to go out didn't
they don't even try it
oh oh that's what you were doing
oh thank you bersonin events for fixing
the lights ad-lib I don't care
hello no one okay there's a bench let me
see what a parade anything
let's see you not blow up getting the
flamethrower that's for sure I could get
the damage ah
I need to get better and throwing to be
in business all fire
what's the alt fire for this
oh no I don't know whatever it brought
don't matter damage reload damages
that's a nice straight road to damage
not bad I'm pretty sure I'm gonna keep
lying just do a damage capacity for that
here no nothing in the immediate range
detonator love me some detonator it's
too far for the next it's more of a
situational thing I think I need a
bigger duration for this definitely
because the Derr Derr up in her because
that's been a big problem like hardly
lasts like in the original dead space of
the stasis left ever even when it wasn't
upgrade it lasted forever even though it
locked down a group full on give me my
sick one coming
give me my save point thank you sir
Adam oh it was it okay one second
he saved must save the world so I'm not
gonna pop out at me I knew it was I
wasn't supposed to trust these anything
else in here
all right who's out there
and I'll
this is a long one ah oh come on
why all these vents rickety if there's
suppose of us withstand space I think I
can get oh it's dark is like so dark oh
hello there's like redonkulous ly darker
is that ten thousand Hot Diggity okay
what I need is oh no any I'm a switch
out to them oh that's how you switch
tabs you just hit one two or three
switching out to the line gun
it is so dark
back in the darkness secret I probably
even a mechanistic remedy okay
sorry if you guys can't see anything but
I can barely see anything outside my
flashlight anyway line Rex okay
I could already buy those I've got like
all the ammo in the ammo store heard
this boy oh I love it they're giving me
all the detonator hmm love the detonator
love it love it ash rubble we shouldn't
love it because it's gonna get me killed
I know but still love it was that like
him music is ominous hi oh it's a baby
Babu
yeah oh baby you want some oh yeah yeah
get me our goodies
get me your goodies oh love hey doctor I
don't care if it's called the detonator
I'm calling the grenade launcher in to
kill just about haha actually that's all
the time I got for this episode thank
you all so much for watching as always
I'll see you in the next part but I